from the daily wire it says a virginia
court ruled monday that there is enough
evidence to find
that a teen accused of sexually
assaulting a fellow student at loudoun
county high school bathroom in may
engaged in non-consensual sex i.e it was
a rape the daily wire broke the story of
the sexual assault in lounge county last
month
bringing to light two alleged rapes at
two separate schools one of which
involved scott smith's daughter smith
was later arrested at a loudly county
school board meeting so we know about
that
the teen who appeared in court on monday
is standing trial in two separate cases
so
we have we finally have an official
confirmation of that as well because we
heard about the second rape and it
wasn't officially confirmed
that it was by the same student but now
that's official as well
one involving a student at stonebridge
high school and a different incident in
a classroom at broad run high school
both in the loudoun county school
district so
there was a girl raped in a bathroom
and then that the rapist is sent to a
different school
where he then rapes a stude a a
fellow student in a classroom this time
the teen who reportedly identifies as
gender fluid is alleged to have
assaulted scott miss scott smith's
daughter in a girl's restroom at
stonebridge while wearing a skirt
despite indications that he had
committed a serious crime the boy was
was then transferred
so
this is this is confirmation the rape
did occur
um we know that the cover-up happened
too
we have absolute confirmation of that
we know that it happened because we have
the loudoun county school board on
record we have the superintendent on
record
saying that they had no information of
any assaults happening in bathrooms
when we know that they did we know that
they were told about it so we know they
lied there was absolutely a cover-up no
question about it we don't have to say
alleged
we don't have to say alleged about the
rape either now
these are things that happened
so what's the media going to do um
they've tried ignoring this they can't
fully ignore it because we have we have
forced them to acknowledge it
and so now they are retreating to
what in any other circumstance they
would call victim blaming so here is
justin juvenal
who's a reporter um
calls himself a justice reporter
ironically enough
for the washington post and he he posted
he said a teen testified she met a
classmate for consensual sex in the
girls bathroom of a loudoun county high
school before
but in a may encounter she was sexually
assaulted
new details in the case of the center
for firestorm
now even that detail
that according to the washington post
this teen girl had a previous um
had previous sexual encounters previous
consensual sexual encounters with this
boy
but in this case it was not consensual
now adding in that detail
especially making it sort of a headline
justin here posted it on twitter making
it kind of the headline
in any other circumstance
that would be called victim blaming
and for good reason actually because
what what what difference does that make
what does it have to do with anything
because because in the past she's she'd
had consensual encounters with this
this what 14 year old girl had had
consensual 14 or 15 year old years old
had consensual encounters with this boy
that means what does that mean it
doesn't mean anything at all
the fact is she did not consent in this
case and so that's rape
but there is
given what's at stake here as far as the
left and the media is concerned
you know there's there's
it's really two levels
first of all this is about assaults in
public school
and a public school cover-up
something that
as we've talked about on this show
is endemic in the public school system
there is a there is a real sexual
assault
epidemic a crisis in the school system
and there has been for decades
and before we ever
injected any of the gender ideology
aspects into any of these stories the
media had no interest in talking about
it
because it's the public school system if
we're going to talk about
um epidemics of sexual assault they much
you know they're fine talking about it
in hollywood even though hollywood is
left-wing they certainly would would
like talking about it in in the catholic
church
but not in the public school system
so already they're pre-predisposed to
ignore these cases and then you add in
the fact
that this kid is gender non-conforming
this happened in a bathroom
at a time when the school board was
pushing through a policy to open up the
bathrooms for boys and girls to share
together
you add in that and
there is no level they won't to which
they will not stoop
to include victim blaming well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content